[Music]
seawater
is salty undrinkable
and a potential source of planet-saving
fuel
hold up fuel
yeah that's right we have the technology
to convert seawater into liquid fuel
could your car use it would it be
carbon neutral and
how would it affect your vacation plans
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we powered the planet with sea water
you're up in the air staring down at the
beautiful ocean below
it's your first carbon neutral flight
and
you couldn't be more excited sure the
tickets were a little more expensive but
jet setting without the environmental
cost of carbon emission
is well worth it you think
about how amazing it is that the very
ocean
below you is the same thing powering
this large commercial jet
but how did we get here
in 2014 the united states navy
successfully created liquid hydrocarbon
fuel from seawater
they did this by extracting carbon
dioxide
and hydrogen gas from seawater and using
a relatively cheap catalyst to convert
carbon dioxide
into carbon monoxide and
just in case i lost you there a catalyst
is
a chemical that lowers the amount of
energy needed for
another chemical reaction to happen
this chemical reaction is complete the
carbon monoxide
is transformed into fuel
the us navy was able to generate four
liters a day
in the pilot program scaled up this
seawater technology could completely
replace fossil fuels which
would be a big deal
[Music]
in 2017 the us military bought
269 230 barrels of oil
every day burning all this fuel
emitted over 25 000 kilotons of carbon
dioxide
not only that but because this seawater
fuel
is liquid it could be used in existing
cars and airplanes
and with transportation being
responsible for 14
of all greenhouse gas emissions
developing this
alternative fuel source would help us
eliminate almost
100 billion metric tons of carbon
dioxide from our atmosphere
by the year 2050 the immediate cost
would be more expensive than oil but
if we don't cut our greenhouse gas
emissions in half
by 2030 severe storms
droughts and famine await and
it's probably much better to spend a
little more up front
to avoid such a mess
there are three big advantages to this
alternative fuel source
first the resource is abundant since
70 of our planet is covered by ocean
we already have a lot of sea water ready
to go
second most modern day objects already
use
liquid fuels so it would be an easy
conversion
and third liquid fuels are easier to
transport
compared to gas
[Music]
if you put this new seawater fuel into
your current car
you wouldn't notice any difference it
would look and smell the same
you would still be emitting carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere when you
drove around but
because you're only emitting the exact
amount of carbon dioxide that was
extracted from the seawater initially
it's a carbon neutral fuel source
of course it would only be truly carbon
neutral
if the whole process was also carbon
neutral
from building the liquid storage tanks
to pumping water and
creating the catalyst it would all have
to release zero carbon dioxide which
means
we would still need to supplement the
process with wind or solar energy
you see this method of creating liquid
fuel
is still early in the developmental
process even so
it's important to support new technology
being created
to replace our current harmful fossil
fuel consumption
raise your voice and encourage a cleaner
and greener future
we need to push our governments to move
forward responsibly and
invest in technology and practices that
could save our planet
maybe we could raise money for green
tech by
charging corporations for any pollution
they inflict on our environment
but that's a story for another
what if
you